Geschichte scheint sich doch zu
wiederholen aus dem fernen Osten
erreichen uns Nachrichten über die
Neubildung einer Achse des Bösen
Russland und Nordkorea lange geübt als
Unruhestifter und Aggressoren wollen
militärisch kooperieren um die Ukraine
doch noch in die Knie zu zwingen ein
Zeichen für moskausstärke oder eher ein
Hilferuf aus dem Kreml
Ukraine in der Gegen Offensive wie stark
ist Putin unter Druck jetzt der
königsrunde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Julia Friedländer ist bei uns
Geschäftsführerin der Atlantikbrücke sie
waren früher auch tätig als Beraterin
für das
US-Finanzministerium wie auch für das
Weiße Haus Rüdiger Lüdeking ist
deutscher Botschafter außer Diensten sie
waren als deutscher Vertreter bei der
Organisation für
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
OSZE und dort waren ihre Themen vor
allem Sicherheitspolitik
Rüstungskontrolle und auch Abrüstung
Professor Alexander Lippmann in Moskau
geboren ist Professor für
Politikwissenschaften mit Schwerpunkt
Osteuropa und Russland am Osteuropa
Institut der Freien Universität Berlin
und wie viel gilke ist Osteuropa
Historiker und Ukraine Experte bei der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik sie haben mehrere Jahre in Kiew
gelebt und geforscht und auch ein Jahr
in Moskau erlebt man
wladimir Putin hat sich ja gestern
mutmaßlich tatkräftige Waffenhilfe durch
den nordkoreanischen Machthaber Kim
jong- und gesichert was sagt das
eigentlich mit den bisherigen Erfolg der
sogenannten
spezialoperation aus russischer Sicht
aus na ja dass die spezialoperation
nicht nach Plan läuft wissen wir
mindestens seit anderthalb Jahren
eigentlich seit wenigen Wochen wenige
Wochen nach dem Anfang des Krieges war
es klar die jetzige Lage mit Nordkorea
zeigt eigentlich das Russland jetzt auch
aus verschiedenen zum Teil früher aus
ungewöhnlich gehaltenen Quellen versucht
Waffenlieferungen zu bekommen und dann
nordkoriert tatsächlich enorme Waffen
Vorräte hat über Jahrzehnte angesammelt
wurden stellt das Land ein geeigneten
Partner gerade in diesem Bereich vor ist
die ukrainische gegen Offensive
tatsächlich so erfolgreich das Putin
jetzt in
Pjöngjang um Waffen Nachsuchen muss also
ich würde es umgekehrt formulieren sie
ist eben nicht so erfolglos wie das in
den letzten Wochen dargestellt wurde ich
habe das auch schon vor Wochen gesagt
diese Offensive wird lange dauern was
wir sehen ist dass die Ukraine sehr
beharrlich Dinge tun und langsam
vorangehen dass aber sehr konsistent tun
und wir davon ausgehen können dass sie
deswegen glauben dass das Erfolg hat und
was wir gesehen haben zum Beispiel im
Süden sind eben die Probleme bei der
Artillerie auf der russischen Seite die
Ukraine hat in den letzten Wochen zum
ersten Mal hatte darüber Überlegenheit
gehabt es wurde bei Eroberung von
Dörfern zum Teil nicht mehr
zurückgeschossen mit Arterie auf
russischer Seite und ich denke damit
haben jetzt auch diese
vorratsbeschaffung auch zu tun
ist es denn inzwischen wahrscheinlicher
geworden dass der Krieg durch Verhandeln
beendet werden kann es gibt auch Zeichen
Anzeichen Signale von silenski bezüglich
vermeintliches Signale be wirklich der
Krim also ich fürchte nein obwohl wir
sind natürlich jetzt in einer Phase des
Krieges die eigentlich danach ruft das
auf eine Verhandlungslösung
hingearbeitet wird oder zumindest auf
einen Waffenstillstand denn jeden Tag
sterben da tausende wahrscheinlich
tausende von Soldaten und wir sind in
einem abnutzungskrieg der kaum Erfolge
bringt und auch beide Seiten vermutlich
mal werden vielleicht auch realisiert
haben dass sie ihre ursprünglichen
Kriegsziele nicht so ohne weiteres
erreichen werden und hier wird schon
gesagt es wird ein länger Krieg es
werden und dann stellt sich die Frage
wie lange wird er noch gehen und ich
wünschte mir eigentlich dass mehr auf
eine Verhandlungslösung hingewirkt würde
auch auf politischer Ebene und das fehlt
mir zu sehr
bislang stehen die USA vielleicht müssen
wir besser sagen die US Administration
fest an der Seite der Ukraine jetzt hebt
in den USA langsam der
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf im Herbst
nächsten Jahres an
auch gerade wenn die Erfolge der Ukraine
möglicherweise noch auf sich warten
lassen der Krieg sich in die Länge zieht
wird jetzt der Druck aus Washington auf
Russland und auch möglicherweise der
Druck durch Waffenlieferungen nachlassen
ich glaube nicht mit der Zeit wird
natürlich ihr seht jeder fragen wie lang
wird das dauern wie viel wird wieder das
Kosten und was hat das unseren eigenen
Vorräten zu tun die ersten Ausschüsse im
US-Kongress haben schon stattgefunden ja
fragen also in meiner Ehemann Kollegen
aus dem Finanzministerium und aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium wurden schon
gefragt also wie wohin geht es dann und
ich glaube es ist irgendwie was schon
erwähnt wurde in der Frage der Zeit wie
schnell können wir die Ukraine
unterstützen damit sie zu einem
womöglich in Standpunkt kommen dass sie
verhandeln können und es ist wir spielen
eben in die Ukraine gegen Zeit und eben
nicht mit der us-ministration
gerade gesagt ja ich würde gerade direkt
auf das was gesagt wurde geantwortet
also ich glaube das
zur Zeit überhaupt keine Verhandlung in
Sicht sind das muss man ganz klar sagen
die Ukraine wenn man sich auf die
Umfragen anguckt jetzt die jüngsten
Umfragen vom vom dif-institut in Kiew
sind nicht bereit für einen
Waffenstillstand und zwar deswegen weil
sie auch keine irgendwelche Konzession
von Putin sehen Putin hat nach dieser
pregorian Meuterei die ich selbst an
sich nicht überwerten möchte das System
relativ schnell konsolidiert ich sehe
auch dort keine Gefährdung aber
umgekehrt ist es so dass der Krieg für
Putin wichtig für sein macht er halt
geworden ist im Grunde genommen hat
dieses Regime das sehr pervers noch
personalistischer geworden ist jetzt
erstmal so die Perspektive bis zu den
nächsten Wahlen aber im Grunde genommen
gibt es keine auf putinischer Seite und
russischer Seite sehen wir eigentlich
keine Kriegsziel Strategie was könnten
denn Kriegsziele sein sondern was wir
wiederholt gesehen haben ist
demeditarisierung denazifizierung der
Ukraine und zu selenski ganz kurz das
unterscheidet sich nicht von dem was er
denn sie immer gesagt hat so Grimm er
hat wie gesagt dass die Krim das sagt er
immer wieder nicht unbedingt erobert
werden muss sondern es kann auch eine
Mischung von diplomatischen und anderen
Mitteln geben wenn wir eine Position
haben die uns diese Möglichkeiten gibt
und die haben die Position noch nicht
und die Krim ist halt von strategisch
hoher Bedeutung für die Souveränität der
Ukraine also kein Kriegsziel erreicht
bzw die Einsicht dass man es nicht
erreichen kann
nähern wir uns der Frage liegt man mal
ob sich vielleicht die ob die Zeit für
für Putin läuft diese ukrainische gegen
Offensive die dauerzeit etwa 14 Wochen
an jetzt gibt es Informationen das etwa
200 50 Quadratkilometer befreit sind
Moskau kontrolliert aber das was sie
2014 annektiert haben oder jetzt besetzt
haben immer noch mehr als 100.000
Quadratkilometer ukrainischen
Staatsgebiets im Herbst das bringt das
Wetter meistens mit sich versinkt dort
alles im Schlamm da geht dann
zumindestens bei den Landstreitkräften
nicht mehr sehr viel ist das ein Vorteil
Putin im Moment naja für Potion ist der
Lage natürlich zurzeit alles andere als
bedrohlich sie haben Recht die
ukrainische Offensive muss man nicht
absolut erfolglos bezeichnen aber dass
die Ziele die Maximalziele von denen man
zum Beispiel in Europa gesprochen hat in
diesem Jahr erreicht werden es ist
glaube ich ziemlich klar dass es nicht
der Fall sein wird und es ist eigentlich
nicht klar ob sie auch längerfristig
erreichbar sein werden und aus dieser
Perspektive ja putin wird wahrscheinlich
seine Maximalziele im Krieg nicht mehr
erreichen es ist ihm auch mittlerweile
klar deswegen übrigens über den
Zertifizierung und die militärisierung
heute auch nicht wirklich gesprochen
wird man spricht gegen den großen Kampf
gegen den Westen jetzt aber das die
russische Armee Stellung hält und dass
man ein Gleichgewicht hat dass vor
Putins Regime zumindest nicht bedrohlich
ist da scheint mir die Tatsache zu sein
aber umso mehr kam es ja darauf an dass
darauf hingewirkt wird dass solche
Verhandlungen beginnen wir haben also
seit März letzten Jahres nicht einmal
mehr Verhandlungen und ich gehe auch
davon aus wann wird immer davon es wird
immer davon gesprochen also gäbe es da
irgendwelche im Hinterzimmer
irgendwelche austausche ich glaube nicht
dass das wirklich so ist und ich war
eigentlich auch entsetzt als man selbst
den sehr allgemein formulierten zwölf
Punkteplan den
China vorgelegt hat der ist sehr
allgemein und trotzdem hat er sich ja
sicher wichtige Punkte wie
Akzeptierung der territoren Integrität
und auch Souveränität von Staaten an die
hätte man anknüpfen können und das das
geht einfach nicht und ich glaube auch
der Westen muss da etwas aktiver werden
auf politischer Ebene und auf Russland
wie auch auf die Ukraine zugehen wir
haben uns jetzt ja zu eigen gemacht die
sehr weitgehende ukrainischen
Kriegsziele die letztlich nur durch
einen Siegfrieden erreichbar wären aber
das weiß ich nicht ich glaube beide
Seiten stehen jetzt vor einer
schwierigen Phase des Krieges die sehr
viele Opfer wahrscheinlich verlangen
wirken kosten wird und wo auch die
Eskalation nicht ausgeschlossen ist also
umso mehr würde sich eigentlich jetzt
anbieten dass eine Intervention
stattfindet auf politischer Ebene um
einen Frieden zu erreichen oder
zumindest ein Waffenstillstand von Druck
aus Washington gesprochen aber in der
Richtung wird es wahrscheinlich kein
Druck von dort hinten ausgeben zu sagen
setzt euch mal zusammen an den Tisch
nein ich glaube das ist es ist kommt
drauf an wie die Ukraine sich verhandeln
und das ist natürlich nicht lediglich
bei uns zu bestimmen wann die
Verhandlungen am Beginn sollen ähm die
Frage ist ist das geht darum also
deswegen hier sind ganze Gespräche
betaurus und
amerikanische Seite also die wir müssen
die Ukraine so stark unterstützen damit
wir zu einem Punkt kommen das überhaupt
überlegbar ist und ich glaube man sollte
nicht frühzeitig sagen wir sollten die
politische Gespräche
vor allem hinter geschlossenen Türen und
ohne die Ukraine beginnen ich glaube es
nicht das liegt nicht bei uns im Sinne
ja ich glaube auch also ich wusste es
noch mal also das mit der Offensive das
stimmt so einfach nicht also alle
Experten und ich wundere mich über die
Diskussion wussten schon im Herbst
letzten Jahres das ist Monate dauern
wird das heißt wenn die Stadt rason und
die Ukraine machen das ja über einen
einsekern sie rücken übrigen langsam
aber sie rücken nach vorne und sie sind
ja jetzt auch an Stellen über die erste
Linie hinweg gekommen wir dürfen auch
nicht vergessen solche schweren
fortifikationen sind immer sehr statisch
wenn da was schief geht sieht hinten
dran sehr schlecht aus aber was sind
wichtiger Punkt ist und das wird hier
vergessen der Süden ist für die Ukraine
lebenswichtig entscheidend wir müssen
uns über Einsen klar sein für Putin ist
die jetzige Situation im Grunde genommen
schon ein Sieg und das ist sehr
gefährlich denn er wird nach einem
Waffenstillstand da bin ich völlig von
überzeugt auch wenn wir uns die
Geschichte der Kriegs Vorbereitung seit
acht Jahren im Süden angucken die
Ukraine wurde ja schon vorher abgewürgt
der hat nur die westliche Diplomatie
völlig geschlafen wenn wir das sehen ist
die Ukraine in der jetzigen Situation in
einer existenziell bedrohlichen Lage und
ich möchte auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass natürlich für die Russen
jetzt sehr problematisch ist wie gezielt
die Ukraine immer mehr reinkommen die
strategischen Ziele im Rückraum der
Russen zu bekämpfen und insofern kann
ich nur warnen davor zu einem falschen
Zeitpunkt die Unterstützung
zurückzufahren und sich naiv auf
Verhandlung einzulassen die Putin gerade
jetzt in einer sehr starken Position
dann gucken wir doch die Waffensysteme
mal an wir hatten gerade schon
angesprochen Nordkorea als Unterstützer
das sind ja alte sowjetische Bestände
die jetzt sozusagen wieder
zurückgeschickt werden nach Russland in
den Nachfolge statt er der Sowjetunion
da gibt es die Informationen diese
sowohl die Artillerie Waffen wie auch
die Munition die sein von schlechter
Qualität veraltet schlecht gelagert es
ist zwar ein bisschen rauen Mengen
vorhanden aber gestern habe ich auch
irgendwo gehört
Hauptsache schlechte schlechte Munition
ist besser als keine Munition möchte ich
allerdings keine Knarre in der Hand
haben wo ein ruckeltierer im Lauf steckt
also wie ist diese Qualität dieser
militärischen Zusammenarbeit zu sehen
damit man naja also ich glaube zunächst
mal die waffenlage Russlands das was
Nord von Nordkorea kommt kommt
hauptsächlich tatsächlich Waffen die
sehr lange gelagert wurden die den
modernen Standards nicht entsprechen
Russland setzt auch zum Teil Waffen von
russischen Lagern FS entfernen Osten die
auch da sehr lange sind aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen die Nachrichten kamen
auch in den letzten Wochen russland hat
die Produktion von Raketen auf den
Vorkriegsstand verbracht oder sogar
vergrößert hat russische Militär
komplett funktionieren also das ist
nicht der Fall das Russland jetzt keine
ausreichenden Munition und Waffen hat
und deswegen würde ich dir
Aufmerksamkeit eigentlich einem ganz
anderen Thema ist das was mit dem Nord
ist sozusagen ein Ablenkungsmanöver oder
eine nebelklasse wenn man vorübergehend
zuschubb und warten bekommt ist es
natürlich hilfreich aber es ist nicht
der Fall dass ohne diesen Deal Russland
dann also relativ modernen Niveau die
russische Armee weil sie holen ja jetzt
aus der Mottenkiste auch 45 Jahre alte
Panzer raus die Sie möglicherweise haben
Sie ja ich glaube 2000 haben sie im
Krieg schon verloren das heißt also das
ist ja auch Ehrenzeichen dass sie das in
das Wasser vielleicht doch bis zum Hals
steht also ja auch nicht vergessen da
oben haben wir in drei ländereck also
Nordkorea Russland und China und das ist
ich würde ich würde es nicht ähm
übersehen dass es vielleicht etwas aus
China und Schleichweg macht durch
Nordkorea nach Russland rein da können
sie den Chinesen dann hochziehen machen
es nicht gemacht aber trotzdem es kommt
magischerweise an möglicherweise werden
die Komponenten die aus deutschen
Unternehmen über illegale
schmuggelwege nach Russland kommen viel
e aktiver sein bei der bei der
Kriegsführung für Russland genau aber
ich glaube das zentrale Problem und
darüber dürfen wir wirklich nicht
vergessen das bringt auch zum Punkt den
Sie angesprochen haben wir sprechen die
ganze Zeit über Waffen aber die knappe
Ressorts der bei Ländern wie die Ukraine
und Russland moderne urbane Nationen
sind Menschen die ukrainische Offensive
fordert unglaubliche Opferzahlen
russland hat im Krieg bereits auch
enorme Opferzahlen gehabt enorme Zahl
der Soldaten die nicht mehr drin über
200.000 umgezogen
genau und für mich ehrlich gesagt wäre
genau das der entscheidende Punkt der
langfristig zu schauen ist der Länder
können einfach nicht uneingeschränkten
Anzug nach Soldaten an die Front liefern
sind keine europäischen Nationen des
Ersten Weltkriegs benötigen Front quasi
ausbluten damit man irgendwann zum zum
Verhandlungstisch man geht ja dann
eigentlich davon aus dass wenn die
beiden Seiten total erschöpft sind das
ist dann doch zu Verhandlungen kommt
selbst wenn es keine klaren Linien gibt
und keinen Siegfrieden
muss noch mal sagen
Putin spielt sicherlich auf Zeit er
wartet natürlich darauf und alle
Äußerungen von republikanischen
Kandidaten für die Wahl laufen darauf
hinaus dass man die Unterstützung der
Ukraine zurückfahren wird und wenn die
Amerikaner das tun dann ist natürlich
Deutschland und sind die Europäer mehr
gefragt aber die können nicht liefern
weil wir letztlich auch nicht auf eine
Kriegswirtschaft bisher umgestellt haben
und ich möchte auch noch mal ein
dringend darauf hinweisen ich meine
es ist natürlich so dass
das
wir in einer Situation sind die
eigentlich nach einem Frieden oder nach
einem Waffenstillstand ruft und ich bin
mir nicht sicher wenn sie sagen ja hier
wird das da dann Russland sich nur
ausruhen würde um dann ein weiteres Mal
anzugreifen ich glaube Putin hat genau
begriffen dass er innerhalb der ersten
14 Tage seinen Krieg verloren hat er
wird seine Kriegsziel nicht erreichen
und entsprechend müsste er eigentlich zu
einem vielleicht gesichtswarenden
Frieden
bereit sein aber das glaube ich wird
ausgeschlossen von westlicher Seite und
ich meine schon vielleicht auch von
Ukraine
dass die Gesichtswahrung ja das ist
natürlich Gesichtswahrung ist natürlich
immer ein ganz großes Problem ich würde
nur sagen man muss sich auch vorsehen
dass man nicht in eine Eskalation
hineinläuft wir reden jetzt über eine
Unterstützung der Ukraine ich bin ganz
dafür und natürlich darf dieser
auch dieser Präzedenzfall den wir da
haben das nämlich ein Staat überfallen
wird und versucht wird mit Gewalt
Fakten zu schaffen das geht ja gegen die
ganz zentrale das ganze zentrale
Gewaltverbot des der verein-karte dass
das darf aber überhaupt keinen keine
Schule machen darf kein präsidenzfall
werden und das sollte eigentlich auch
den Staaten des globalen Südens die sich
natürlich zurückhaltend vermittelbar
sein aber wir müssen natürlich auch
sagen wir wissen nicht genau wie das wie
der Krieg ausgeht und ich will nicht
ausschließen und das wird immer so ein
bisschen unter den Tisch gekehrt
Russland weiter eskaliert und ich könnte
mir vorstellen wenn Putin vor einer mit
dem Rücken zur Wand vor einer
strategischen Niederlage steht dass er
dann eskalieren wird und da stellt sich
dann für mich die Frage warum machen wir
jetzt setzen wir nur
eindimensional auf Waffenlieferung und
auch ein Siegfrieden warum wird nicht
mit gleicher mit dem gleichen Engagement
auch versucht die Verhandlungen in Gang
zu bringen wobei ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl dass Verhandlungen diejenigen die
das fordern werden immer gleich als Pisa
oder sonst wie dargestellt diejenigen
die jedenfalls vielleicht sogar das
Geschäft Putins betreiben das stimmt
nicht ich glaube schon dass der Westen
gerade Westen in den Verhandlungen die
ja bisher geführt hat auch mit der
Sowjetunion und Russland gezeigt hat
dass es gute und Karte Verhandlungen
geben kann da würde ich jetzt gleich die
Frage noch nicht hinterher schicken muss
bei dem anderen Waffensystem das gerade
verloren macht Taurus mit die Ukraine ja
möglicherweise in der Lage ist in die
gegen Offensive effektiv zu unterstützen
indem man alle logistischen Komponenten
im Hinterland der russischen Armee
wirklich effektiv bekämpfen kann und
Russland wahrscheinlich auch wenig gegen
wer hat das könnte den Krieg erheblich
oder vielleicht sogar entscheidend
verändern Stichwort Eskalation die
Befürchtung von der Lüdeking wäre das
ein Waffensystem dass das eskaliert was
bisher bei bei Schützenpanzern bei
Kampfpanzern und auch der Ankündigung
Flugzeuge Kampfflugzeuge zu liefern noch
nicht der Fall war nee ich glaube das
ist auch wieder ein Missverständnis wie
Putin funktioniert Putin versucht uns
genau in diese selbst Abschreckung
hinein zu triggern und wenn wir uns
angucken was passiert ist und das ist
ein Fakt als neue Waffen geliefert
wurden ist es eben nicht zu der
Eskalation gekommen sondern Putin hat
sowieso eskaliert also Putin eskaliert
auch wenn man sich zurückhält und zwar
als skelier eskalierte asymmetrisch weil
der symmetrisch nicht installieren kann
also zum Beispiel Staudamm Nova karovka
die Entziehung natürliche
Lebensgrundlagen so funktioniert er und
was wir mit dieser Debatte machen ist
wir delegitimieren und Unterstützung die
von dem Völkerrecht weit abgesichert ist
wir sind weit unter den roten Linien des
Völkerrechts wir haben es mit einer
völlig asymmetrischen Situation zu tun
und ich möchte auch noch mal sagen was
ganz wichtig ist es geht ja nicht darum
dass jetzt die also siegfriedenheit ich
übrigens auch für den völlig falschen
Begriff es geht einfach darum dass die
Ukraine an einem bessere Position kommt
und da geht es um 15 bis 20 km es geht
darum dass die Ukraine mit ihrer jetzt
sehr guten Artillerie und ihren
marschflughörnern die logistikel ist
Linie der UK der Krim zu Norden
durchbrechen können das sind ganz
strategische Ziele und auf deren
strategischen Ziele muss man sich gerade
im Sinne von späteren konstruktiven
Handlungen einstellen und die viel
besser machen ein wichtiger Punkt ist
auch mit dem führt er den Krieg dann
weiter also ich bin mir sicher Putin hat
seine weitergehenden Ziele die ja mit
der Ukraine verbunden sind nämlich die
Dominanz im Schwarzmeerraum natürlich
nicht aufgegeben das ist warum er das
ganze macht das ist nicht ein Krieg
gegen die Ukraine das ist jetzt schon
ein Krieg der auch gegen uns geführt
wird und ich weiß nicht ob wir auf diese
Herausforderung eingestellt sind wenn
wir jetzt den Fehler machen zu einem
falschen Zeitpunkt der Ukraine die
Möglichkeit geben in der besseren
Position sein ich glaube es ist kein
logischer Gegensatz zwischen zwei
Aussagen die eine Aussage ist das Gute
natürlich
schreckenspirale schaffen wird und
schaffen will und das ist auch ganz
normal in den internationalen
Beziehungen dass man versucht sich an
unvorhersage war zu präsentieren
eskalieren zu präsentieren das bedeutet
aber nicht gleichzeitig dass die
nukleare Eskalation unmöglich ist und da
befürchte ich muss ich Ihnen leider
zustimmen ähm ich würde die Eskalation
nicht mit der Verwendung von konkreten
Waffen verbinden nicht mit tauches
Raketen oder Leopard Panzern an der
Front der Eskalation befürchtete ist
wird sehr wahrscheinlich in dem
Augenblick in dem Putins Regime wackelt
hat ja auch glaube ich die USA genau an
der Stelle sind sie auch manchmal
vorsichtig und weil sie diese Eskalation
ja auch vermeiden wollen das jetzt
mehrfach schon die das Stichwort
gefallen
US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf ist ja
gerade auf einer Good Will Tour durch
republikanisch dominierte
US-Bundesstaaten um dem Schlimmsten
vorzubeugen dass Donald Trump z.B oder
gesandtes oder andere Präsident werden
macht das Sinn das dass man oder muss
man wirklich damit rechnen wenn bei
beiden oder die Demokraten die Wahl
verlieren dass Putin sagt das ist genau
das ist was er anschließt natürlich der
Wette drauf aber die amerikanische
Politik ist viel komplizierter als ich
mir so vorstellt oder was wenn man
Schlagzeilen liest also ich war am
Weißen Haus als wir also unter Trump das
Beamten da der Trump und Weißen Haus
damals haben wir die ersten Waffen die
du keine verkauft das war nicht Obama
das war unter Tram
gewesen ein bisschen man das kann man
nicht so pauschal schwarz-weiß bemalen
und dann um da spielt natürlich Congress
in der sehr große Rolle spielen ja auch
wie sie gerade erwähnen die Gouverneure
und ich bin fester Meinung die große
Mehrheit der Partei steht hinter der
Ukraine natürlich wollen sie auch China
erwähnen und sagen wir müssen darauf
achten dass wir nicht wissen wie zwei
glasig fahren in unsere Strategie aber
bei solange wir unsere Beschaffung in
standhalten und das bei uns passiert ist
ein bisschen besser als hier in
Deutschland muss man sagen
da da stehen die USA
die deutschen deswegen nicht gemacht
angeblich keine Deals machen kann also
wenn der jetzt mit der Ukraine ist
Präsidenten die machen kann dann macht
er das auch und dann hätte Putin auf den
falschen Gaul gesetzt also mit natürlich
wissen wir dass es mit der Ukraine also
ein kompliziert waren
er versucht immer diesen Deal zu machen
die sind immer schlechte Idee ist ja und
und er
profitiert auch schlechte schlechte
Maßnahmen wenn wir da auch ihr auch
schlechte Karten bekommen verkauft das
alles was Gutes also ich glaube nicht
dass man ihn wie da überlegen kann da
findet er dann die richtige Lösung also
ich noch mal ganz kurz weil das nämlich
häufig auch in der Medien so ist also
man wird immer das wird immer gesagt ja
man geht im Putin auf dem Leim und er
hat weitergehende Ziele er will dumm er
will auch vielleicht Europa dominieren
wie das mal auch beschrieben worden ist
ich halte das für nicht richtig dass man
ihm auf den Leimen geht und das ist ganz
klar dass das sollte man also auch nicht
und man muss also nicht die üblichen
Diskussion um den Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen ernst nehmen er hat
natürlich nicht das Interesse das zu tun
gleichzeitig müssen wir natürlich auch
feststellen dass finde ich manchmal ein
bisschen befremdlich dass wir in Europa
nicht das tun was ich eigentlich für
erforderlich hielte im Rahmen dessen was
man in der Nation üblicherweise macht
nämlich
die Doppelstrategie der von des hamell
Berichtes von 1967 einzuhalten das
nämlich einerseits wäre eine gesicherte
Verteidigungsfähigkeit herstellen und
bewahren und auf dieser Basis kann man
dann auch aus
aber
fragen nachhaken glauben Sie nicht dass
Putin die größte Bedrohung für Putin ja
nicht die NATO ist oder die Waffen der
NATO sondern das westliche
Gesellschaftssystem Westeuropa vor dem
er Angst hatte der gesehen in
Weißrussland das in Belarus was passiert
wenn sich das Volk da erhebt das genau
das das Kriegsziel letztendlich von
Putin ist nämlich gar nicht so sehr die
Ukraine die liegt einfach nur dazwischen
sondern das ist einfach Europa ist das
ist ein Dorn im Auge und die
Sicherheitsgarantien der er braucht
werden ja eigentlich dass die Europäer
sozusagen ihren liberalen Rechtsstaat
aufgeben damit Russland nicht das sind
die Angst hat dass sozusagen sich diese
Überzeugungen nach Russland ausbreiten
also ich weiß nicht ich glaube Putin
kann doch als jemand noch gelten der
kalkuliert er hat sich sehr stark
verkalkuliert beim Beginn des Krieges
weil er sich nämlich erhofft hat dass
innerhalb von 14 Tagen das ganze vorbei
sein würde und ein Marionettenregime in
Kiew eingerichtet werden würde und das
wird also nicht erreichbar sein das muss
ja auch wissen und jetzt weiß ich auch
nicht welche Kriegsziele er tatsächlich
verfolgt sicherlich wird er verfolgen
was
er da annektiert hat als oblasste aus
der Ostukraine und aus der Südukraine
aber wie weit das auch noch verfolgen
wird weiß ich selber das nicht denn er
wird auch sicher sein sehr die
russischen Streitkräfte haben sich
eingegraben und ich finde schon und das
meine ich wird wahrscheinlich notwendig
sein er fühlt sich natürlich bedroht in
seiner Rolle als groß macht er wollte
natürlich gerne die so wird ihn nun
wieder in der wieder schaffen das wird
er nicht schaffen gleichzeitig ist er
sich aber auch bewusst dass er
wahrscheinlich so
irgendwelche roten Linien aufstellen
wird und dazu hat er ja schon 208 und
2014 Georgien und auch also den Kaufkurs
kann man so Kaukasus kann man sagen und
auch Ukraine gemacht er wird sich sicher
sein das wird er also auch nicht wagen
dass er die baltischen Staaten angreifen
wird in einem nächsten Schritt denn dazu
sind auch die russischen Streitkräfte
viel zu sehr entzaubert worden und es
wird lange dauern bevor sie wieder den
Stand Erreichen der erforderlich wäre um
überhaupt solche Gedanken zu liegen
gleichzeitig muss ich aber auch sagen
die NATO Debatte geht mir auch so ein
bisschen zu kurz denn äh ist das zwei
Prozent Ziel was immer ausgegeben wird
für die für den Anteil des
Verteidigungshaushalts am Bib das wird
nicht ausreichen auch für uns nicht um
die erheblichen Lücken zu schließen und
wir haben ja schon gesehen dass es jetzt
ein großes Problem gibt überhaupt
aufzustocken von 180.000 auf 213.000 und
da finde ich muss man also viel
dramatischer rangehen auch auf
westlicher Seite klarer und das als
Priorität ausgeben und das schließt für
mich auch ein dass man sich überlegt ob
man nicht doch wieder eine
Dienstpflicht oder eine
wehrpflichtschaft also ich würde
vielleicht auch noch mal genau das denke
ich ein wichtiger Punkt also was wir auf
jeden Fall und das hat eigentlich steht
das nicht im Gegensatz zu Verhandlungen
wir müssen uns darüber im Klaren sein
dass wir die Ukraine sowieso weiter
unterstützen müssen egal wo dieser Krieg
zum Stillstand kommt denn putin wird
verhandeln und schießen das hat er im
Don Bass gemacht da hat er nie aufgehört
es gab auch nie einen richtigen
Waffenstillstand die Verhandlungen zu
den implementierungspaketen sind ja
unter Kriegsbedingungen erpresst worden
das muss man ganz klar sagen und das
wird er jetzt wieder tun ich möchte noch
mal sagen ich denke wir unterschätzen
ihn schon wieder er wird bestimmte
Protein wird Ziele nicht aufgeben er ist
auch sehr noch ideologischer geworden
als er war er hatte auch immer ein i
pädagogischen Blick er war nicht nur der
kalkulierende fsb-mann und ich möchte
schon noch mal darauf verweisen dass zu
einem jetzigen Zeitpunkt man sich klar
sein muss wenn die Unterstützung
aufhören würde wäre das für die Ukraine
ein Riesenproblem weil noch einmal die
Ziele von Putin sind nicht nur die
Ukraine die Ukraine liegt für ihn wie
ein Block
für weiterführen weiterreichendes Design
was er sehr sehr konsistent verfolgt hat
über acht Jahre und der andere Punkt ist
den man auch vielleicht noch mal sehen
muss ist mit der Abschreckung also ich
glaube Abschreckung ist natürlich ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt und wir müssen ja
aufpassen wir müssen das jetzt zu Ende
denken wenn wir argumentieren er könnte
irgendeine wann mal eine Atomwaffe
einsetzen und uns auf das einfach so
einlassen dann wird die Situation
natürlich erpressbar irgendwann ich
denke ein wichtiger Punkt ist dass wir
auf jeden Fall auf einer Basis einer
gesicherten Abschreckung agieren müssen
und wir haben ja von den Amerikanern
diese klare Kommunikation in diesem und
im letzten Jahr gehabt was passiert wenn
er einen taktischen auf den Sender unter
diesem Aspekt ist der westensatz
zögerlich mit seinen Waffenlieferungen
wir haben ja schon die ganzen
Komponenten angesprochen sollen jetzt
nächstes Jahr F16
um die Jahreswechsel F16 Kampfjets dort
eingesetzt werden
möglicherweise andere Waffensysteme noch
Taurus die Ukraine sagte das dauert
alles zu lange ist der Westen
tatsächlich zu zögerlich also ich bin
nicht ich bin in diesem Bereich nicht so
hundertprozentig Experten aber ich
glaube ich fürchte ja also wir wissen ja
genauso anschauen welche Karten spielen
wir denn was ist unsere Strategie unsere
Strategie ist wie sie erwähnen dass sie
Ukraine eben mal auf also stärkere Hand
hat aber wenn man es sowieso nach und
nach mir dieses Land am Leben hält
militärisch dann schaffen wir eigentlich
nichts dann sterben hunderttausende und
unsere Strategie ist ja auch ein
Scherben ich glaube wir wir
unterschätzen für uns selbst und ich
glaube das ist also ob ich dir also wenn
ich dich finanziellen Themen ja auch
erwähnen darf das Volkswirten hier es
geht ja auch darum dass wir immensen
Druck auf Putin gesetzt haben durch
unser sensionen durch die
Exportkontrollen ja sie sind ja ein Sieb
ja wir wissen ist man kann ja die
umgehen mit der Zeit ja aber man muss ja
auch nicht ignorieren dass wir also
Russland er muss jetzt Putin muss jetzt
also mit ähm Verbindlichkeiten mit mit
Kindern und ja schmieden ja 2014 als er
diesen Krieg ursprünglich angefangen hat
standen ja in dir zum Mistral mit
Frankreich auf dem Tisch das ist ein
komplette Kurswechsel für Putin und wir
haben jetzt auch durch unser
finanzdienstsystem auch geschafft na gut
dass wir Sanktion sprechen da muss ich
auch als Volk leider eingreifen da sehe
ich leider ganz anders als sie ich
befürchte dass was wir gezeigt haben mit
dem letzten anderthalb Jahren ist das
der Sanktion gegen ein Land der so groß
wie Russland so intensiv verflochten mit
dem digitalen Süden dermaßen unwirksam
sind dass sie am Ende nicht nur das Ziel
nicht erreichen dass man ursprünglich
formuliert hat sondern eigentlich zu
Unterstützung von Putins Regime dienen
und das ist nicht genau der Punkt den
ich ansprechen wollte dein Gesicht
dessen was Sie gesagt haben Putins
Furcht vor dem Export des westlichen
Modells sind Russland ich muss zugeben
diese Furcht ist wahrscheinlich im
letzten anderthalb Jahren geringer
geworden denn als Putin jetzt gesehen
hat er hat gesehen dass sein Regime
unter Stress durchaus funktionsfähig ist
dass seine Wirtschaft unter Stress
durchaus funktionsfähig ist wir haben
jetzt ein Land in dem real Löhne massiv
steigen in den Regionen ja indem die
Wachstumsraten sie würden mir sagen wer
darf es natürlich nicht vergleichen aber
sind trotzdem hören
aus meiner Sicht genau das umgekehrte
gewirkt sie haben Putin inzwischen
gestärkt und nicht geschwächtigt glaube
ich so in der Eindeutigkeit nicht was
ich auch so sehe ist dass die Lücken da
sind die übrigens selbst verschuldet
sind zum Teil von der EU
ich möchte nur mal auf eine Sache
hinweisen die man auch durchaus
bearbeiten kann und ich glaube das wäre
ganz wichtig wenn sie sich mal angucken
welche Räder rein für Putin das Öl
transportiert haben und wir müssen
wissen die öleinkünfte sind ganz
wesentlich für die Staatseinnahmen dann
waren das 50% durch griechische Räder
weil es keine logistikklausel in den
Sanktionen gab und bei den Sanktionen
muss man natürlich wiederum auch ein
strategischen Ansatz haben wir müssen da
auch mit den Drittländern
zusammenarbeiten müssen Drittländern wie
Indien und Brasilien auch Angebote
machen und wir müssen wenn wir auch mit
der Türkei reden müssen wir Angebote
machen um sie zu gewinnen das ist sehe
ich durchaus gerade Möglichkeiten für
umgehungs für die Aussetzung von
umgehungs-
Maßnahmen zu gewinnen also ich denke die
Sanktion erstens mal sie ist nicht so
wir sehen bei bestimmten Waffensystem
Virus in Hamburg Probleme das ist schon
wichtig die Technologie Sanktion ähm
aber ich glaube es gibt gäbe sehr viel
zu tun noch positives äh um die Löcher
bei den finanziellen und sektoralen
Sanktionen zu schließen doch die sind so
viele Kühlschränke nach Kasachstan
geliefert und ein Land das 10 Monate 8
Monate eiskalten Winter hat aber die
Chips eben dann umbauen kann in
russische Waffensysteme das heißt also
in großer Preis Zeit wurde also ich ich
weiß ich bin auch ein bisschen skeptisch
weil wir dachten am Anfang wir können
jetzt in russische Wirtschaften
gucken wie stark unsere Finanzsystem ist
und wie wie entschlossen wir sind aber
ich glaube gleichzeitig man muss man
wirklich erkennen deshalb fristige
finanziellen wirtschaftsfolgen für
Russland
wer wer verleiht jetzt Krediten an
Russland natürlich müssen sie an wie
alle Geld also Geld drucken und und
Kontrollen im innenwirtschaft einführen
aber wie wie wird das auch
wirtschaftlichen Folgen die werden ja
doch von anderen getragen sondern dann
wenn man Bereiche nimmt für die
Informationen
wir eigentlich auf russische Lieferungen
angewiesen waren die auch natürlich
unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ausgemacht
haben wie im Energiebereich also ich bin
da schon der Meinung das ist ein sehr
gemischtes Bild man wird da langfristig
sicherlich eine Wirkung sehen die sieht
man auch teilweise jetzt schon aber
kurzfristig versuchen sich auch andere
dort gut zu tun indem sie zum Beispiel
das Öl was von Russland an an Indien
geliefert werden als
LNG oder alles Gas
an Deutschland zu erheblich höheren
Kosten wieder
exportieren ich würde aber noch ein
eigentlich einen ganz anderen Punkt
machen nämlich die Frage der
Waffenlieferung wir sind immer sehr
kritisch und wir lassen uns immer gerne
von solchen Dingen treiben ich erinnere
nur daran dass auch Präsident beiden da
sehr sehr vorsichtig war und äh das also
auch sehr sehr schrittweise getan hat
und wir müssen natürlich auch sehen dass
diese Waffen die geliefert werden
teilweise unserer
eigenen Streit unseren eigenen
Streitkräften verloren gehen ich habe
dann mit Interesse gelesen dass zum
Beispiel die Amerikaner berechnet haben
dass die stingerraketen die sie ja den
Ukrainer schon geliefert haben dass sie
die innerhalb von zehn Jahren mal gerade
wieder produzieren könnten mit der je
gegenwärtigen Produktionskapazität also
da ist noch viel zu tun auf westlicher
Seite und ich meine auch wenn ich mich
erinnere an die Anfänge dass man zum
Beispiel von einigen Seiten gefordert
hat dass man doch in der Ukraine eine
Flugverbotszone gemacht oder etabliert
hätte das hätte uns sofort in den Krieg
reingezogen und das war immer etwas was
unter anderem auch glaube ich
Bundeskanzler Scholz und Präsident
beiden verbunden hat dass sie dann doch
überlegt haben was können wir tun um
nicht selber Kriegsparteien aber das war
von Anfang an ja genau
wo enden denn diese diese
Waffenlieferung ich glaube halt dass wir
einfach sehr viel Zeit verloren haben
wir wussten seit Mai 22 was die Ukraine
braucht und dann hat sie es ersten Jahr
später eigentlich bekommen und das ist
das Problem und zwar weil wir nicht
richtig erkannt haben wo sie eigentlich
geht ich glaube wir haben immer noch
nicht erkannt
was da für uns auf dem Spiel steht bei
diesem Krieg und es ist einfach so auch
wenn gesagt wird ich bin ja auch für
Verhandlungen natürlich nur muss man
auch mal sagen wie sollen die denn
stattfinden denn das Problem ist
natürlich jetzt das Protein und da er
wird von seinen Positionen überhaupt
nicht abrücken er wird natürlich
überhaupt keine territorie
einzugeständnisse machen und das ist
eben für die Ukraine ein großes Problem
auch deswegen weil das Sterben nicht
aufhört ich erinnere mich untersuche das
ja auch sehr intensiv die
Besatzungspolitik ist eine Politik der
Auslöschung des ukrainischen Elements
also für die Menschen in der
Besatzungszone geht der Krieg weiter
auch wenn es irgendeinen grauen
Waffenstillstand geht das muss man auch
immer im Hinterkopf haben aber noch
einmal ich glaube eben dass wir unsere
Möglichkeiten der Unterstützung was man
ja jetzt von der Bundesregierung viel
aktiver macht das muss man ja auch
deutlich sagen dass man die dass man da
natürlich noch viel mehr Möglichkeiten
hat und dass man der Ukraine diese
Möglichkeit wenn es realistische
Möglichkeiten gibt dass die Ziele
erreichen kann auch auch geben muss wir
haben ja wir sind in die Sendung
eingestiegen mit der Suche Putins nach
Verbündeten auf der Welt da gibt es ja
nicht nur Nordkorea da gibt's vor allen
Dingen China erlebt man viel wichtiger
noch für Russland um Unterstützung zu
bekommen dass man Waffen
wirtschafts-hilfe Waffenlieferungen und
so weiter wenn man sich jetzt dem doch
durchaus stärkeren in China so in den
Armen wirft dann könnten aus dieser
Umarmung durch China eines Tages Putin
und Russland kaum noch Luft bekommen
kann das sein dass letztendlich die
Konsequenz ist dass China dann für eine
Art ja zweiter Geige in der Russland zu
einer Art zweiter Geige hinter China
wird die Frage ist halt was China aus
dem Beziehungen zwischen Russland durch
China erreichen will und so wie ich das
jetzt zumindest sehen würde ist die Lage
jetzt nicht die das Putin da massiv
fürchten muss dass China andere Ziele
verfolgen wird als Putin das selbst
macht
Putin und PIN sind gleicher Weise daran
interessiert den westlichen Einfluss zu
begrenzen China schaut sehr aufmerksam
auf Russland wie Russland Sanktionen
umgeht weil eben China sich auch auf
ähnlichen Wirtschaftskrieg vorbereitet
in der absehbaren Zukunft und für sie
ist einfach enorm wichtig das Putins
Regime auch alle möglichen
Stressfaktoren übersteht dementsprechend
ja der chinesische Einfluss wird da sein
aber die strategischen Ziele von Peking
und von Putins Regime in Moskau die
Stimme bereit spielte der USA vor allen
Dingen auf den Hauptkonkurrenten China
Russland überhaupt noch eine Rolle
mittel und langfristig ja also auf jeden
Fall also man schaut ja genauso um an
den letzten Jahren dass wir eine eine
große also Weltmacht Verschiebung
erfahren also gestern hat Toni blinken
eine sehr wichtige Rede in Washington
gehalten vor allem wie geschrieben hat
dieser Post
Post Post
Zeit also wie zu Ende ist und wir
mussten mich eine viel komplizierteren
Welt rechnen wo das irgendwie eben
multipolar ist also man ich glaube das
schafft ja auch Möglichkeiten mit
anderen mit vielen anderen Partnern also
gute dieses zu schmieden und ich meine
einen guten dir es nicht schlechte die
jetzt aber warte mal das Gefühl dass die
USA vor allem nur auf China gucken China
gucken und deswegen ja viele in USA
sagen also Russland lass mal das ist
eigentlich Angelegenheit der Europäer
diese Position gibt's ja auch ja die
Positionen gibt es seit langem die
Europäer soll ein bisschen mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen und ein
bisschen um sich selbst kümmern und das
ist eine das ist das liegt glaube ich
ganz drin bei allen Politikern die
wollte Demokraten republikanernamenten
dass wir unsere Aufgaben aufteilen
müssen und dass sie langfristige
Herausforderung ist ganz eindeutig China
aber das heißt nicht dass das Ukraine
Problem kurzfristig oder gar
mittelfristig
also ich denke auch dass wir haben jetzt
eine Diskussion auch bei den Demokraten
auch eine strategische Diskussion dass
sich die Einsicht ja auch breit macht
gerade wenn wir auf die schwarzen Region
gucken dass man China ja auch nicht nur
einnimmt wenn man im Pazifik aktiv ist
sondern china hat ja eine viel globalere
Strategie und es ist natürlich wichtig
dass die Amerikaner auch in anderen
Orten Präsenz oder zumindest
Unterstützung zeigen sie erste Punkt der
zweite Punkt ist aber das ja auch nicht
nur China für Protein ist für Putin ist
dieser globale Süden der Begriff gefällt
mir aber nicht aber egal ist für ihn
sehr wichtig und das heißt für uns wir
müssen da auch aktiver sein dass wir mit
China wenig erreichen das ist klar aber
wir können natürlich ich sag noch mal
Indien gibt's natürlich ein Interesse
Indien rutscht jetzt aber auch ungewollt
weil es durch sein hohes Wachstum
unheimlichen Bedarf an Energie hat
rutscht jetzt immer mehr eine
Abhängigkeit von Russland ist auch
deswegen nicht bereit was bei den
Sanktionen zu tun aber wenn wir wollen
dass und wir hatten ja auch den Prozess
Kopenhagen Prozess also ganz ohne
Verhandlung das stimmt ja auch nicht es
wird da eine Menge Arbeit reingesteckt
und der ist ganz wichtig dieser
Kopenhagen und gida Track wenn wir
wollen dass wir mit diesen Staaten dass
diese auch wieder und sich uns
anschließen dann müssen wir ihn auch was
anbieten und dann müssen wir halt auch
mal den Indern ein Freihandelsabkommen
anbieten dann muss man halt auch den
brasilienstraße wir können ja nicht nur
sagen also das ist alles für sondern wir
müssen uns auch mal in so einem
indischen Präsidenten hineinversetzen
Minister der hat ja auch große Probleme
mehr da hat ein hohes demokratisches
Wachstum und der kann jetzt nicht
einfach sagen ich mache mal so ich weiß
nicht Umgebung Straße gebaut zur
Seitenstraße zu neuen ähm genau
Reaktion auf das was man jetzt aus dem
Ukraine einem Konflikt um die Ukraine
und dem Überfall auf die Ukraine gelernt
hat also ich glaube die größte Lehre ist
dass wir unsere Außenpolitik immer in
neuen betrachtet haben also das ist auch
glaube ich ein organisatorisches Problem
in unserer Außenpolitik in unseren
Ministerien es gibt die Leute die dann
für China beauftragt für die Erde für
Russland und die Volkswirten sind
entweder drüben ja
das Problem dass wir doch eine sehr sehr
konfrontative Einstellung haben die sehr
stark auch vielleicht emotionsgeladen
ist
das muss ich sagen dass sehe ich mit
großer Sorge denn man war nüchterner
während des Kalten Krieges wo man
natürlich gesagt hat gut wir können
jetzt nicht die was weiß ich 68 die
Demokratie Bestrebungen in der
tschechischen Slowakei können wir nicht
unterstützen weil das eine rote Linie
überschreiten würde und ich habe jetzt
das Gefühl wenn wir jetzt versuchen
Front zu machen sowohl in gegen China
wie gegen Russland dann übernehmen wir
uns und die Lage der Demokratien ist
gerade nicht so rosig dass sie also als
als
Gesellschaftsform so große Attraktivität
entfalten würden und das ist meine große
Problem
von dieser Stelle beenden lassen mit
fortsetzung folgt ganz bestimmt bedanke
mich bei Julia Friedländer bei Wilfried
Jäger Alexander Lippmann und bei Rüdiger
King Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer ich möchte auch ihr aufmerksam
ihre aufmerk oder ihren Augenmerk genau
gesagt auf eine Sendung am Sonntag um
11:30 Uhr lenken unser gesprächsformat
Phönix persönlich in der kühn empfängt
den Filmemacher Stefan Lambi
aktuelles bei Phoenix der Tag mit Thomas
Badezimmer unter anderem der Besuch von
unserer Außenministerin Annalena
baerbock in Washington und da geht es
garantiert auch um die Ukraine bleiben
Sie bei uns
[Musik]